the other thing that you do so well is
you mix it up with people you your crowd
work you mixing it up with people is my
favorite thing is so funny and my
favorite thing they're so often I see
people that do it and it's like that's
okay but it just feels like it's packing
peanuts it's just filler it's not really
getting us anything you really go on the
attack it's not even attack it's a story
that I see when I look at a person I
make up a whole thing and it's so fun to
explore that my main thing when I'm
doing crowd work is to make the person
that I'm talking about laugh just as
hard as everybody else in the room right
so I really do it with joy I never want
anyone to feel like they're feeling
[ __ ] up but you know what that's a lot
like you know one of the greatest of all
time at this if not the greatest was Don
Rickles that's what he achieved too he
would go in he would be tearing into
someone but the person who could feel
would be dying laughing and could feel
his good intent he he would have been
horrified defied if he thought that he
really did hurt someone's feelings
because he was a very sensitive person
and I think you're the same way when I
say attack I mean the energy I meant the
energy and intensity with what you go at
it which is full-throated I'm gonna go
after this person right now but do it in
a way that there's a lot of love in it
it's so funny and it's really funny it's
it's and it's fun for me because I love
making up [ __ ] I love looking at the
person and trying to figure out what's
going on in their life and what I might
think that's going on in their life it
be for me the crowd work is for me like
I'm doing the jokes for y'all the crowd
work is for me because I like to meet
new people I like to talk about people I
like to make people laugh at themselves
I really love making people laugh at
themselves because that is the best
laugh ever because you will laugh at
that even when no one's around you'll go
that [ __ ] was funny what she said about
me God damn it I'm gonna use that myself
like you'll use it yourself like there's
nothing better than when people come
back on my Instagram and be like oh my
God I just got roasted by Leslie oh my
God I'm the song so so girl I'm the it's
so fun yeah I love [ __ ] like that I
remember David Spade came into a comedy
store and I was just on stage just going
just like from from table to table just
just going and he was like what the [ __ ]
so the best way that I can describe how
good I got at crowd work was simply
marvelous I don't know if you know
simply marvelous she was in a lot of
black movies I don't know yeah she was
in one of the Friday movies as John
Witherspoon's wife that's the only thing
I could think of right now but she was a
[ __ ] like she would go from table to
table she taught me a little bit but JB
Smoove gave me the best advice about
crowd work he says that say the first
thing that comes into your mind because
it's usually from God yeah and I'm
telling you every time I've done that it
has destroyed the room like destroyed
the room you know it's crazy that you
said that because I've a long time ago
noticed if something pops into my head
and I just say it 99.9 of the time it
goes well if I stop myself
and think a little more you [ __ ] it up I
[ __ ] it up you [ __ ] it up let me tell
you why because you have two head you
have two people in your head you have
the joke writer and then you have the
performer yeah okay the performer wants
the performance to go right but the joke
writer wants you to tell the joke always
listen to the joke writer the performer
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
the performer does what the joke writer
does it's just that it's a third person
in there the pervert Yeah well we all
have that person we have the third
person he's in there
he sits back and watch all the other
[ __ ]
we're watching the other two and then
to subscribe when they argue oh my God
I literally just did that the other day
on stage there's this line that I've
been using I like to use the real story
I whenever I'm doing a joke I like to
tell the rooster because usually the
real story is hella funny but I thought
of an ALT to this line so while I'm
telling the joke the joke writer and the
performer is completely fighting in my
head complete like yo say this line say
this [ __ ] line I'm telling you right
now that she's gonna kill then before
it's like no that's not what happened
the real thing that happened is actually
funny but it's like no [ __ ] this this is
funny right this will make this joke
just [ __ ] do it you never listen to
me listen to me now and that the Joker
writer one I did the oh [ __ ] kill
yeah but then the performers standing on
the side going well that's not the real
story so what's gonna happen when I want
to do the real story
because that [ __ ] is funny too so what
the [ __ ] you know the answer here is
you're never completely hat if you're
gonna work in comedy I don't care how
hard you kill how things go I think
you're funny you will always leave
feeling a little conflicted a little it
could have gone differently you know
what you are a very busy person and I
promised I would get you out of here
because you have a lot going on we've
been talking that long but you know what
yeah we have but uh this has been a
delight I love you you're fantastic
thank you you're welcome here anytime uh
if you ever want me to sneak by your
apartment at your apartment wow
I do have a pool that's heated
no at your podcast the [ __ ] I want to
make sure I get the word out on the
phone I could listen to you all day and
I will and I'm so glad that you're going
to do this this is going to be a great
format for you it's so good it's perfect
for you and people are going to laugh
but they're also going to be improved by
listening to you absolutely it's so fun
it's the full unfiltered version of me
yeah well I think I think that's always
you
yeah yeah finally
take care Lacy thank you so